[Music]
thank you to you and your awesome team
your work makes a big difference and it
is appreciated what is the most
unexpected benefit you all have
discovered since your journey as the
minimalists began let me say this i'll
say yes big thanks to the team we've got
jordan no more here podcast sean danny
unknown alabama's here emily immigrant
and social jess are not in the room but
then beyond them we're working more with
tk coleman we work with the folks over
at booklight at catalyst you know matt
diabella and the films that we produce
even the folks at extended teams like
jeff and dave our web developer and
designer uh sean mahalic who helps
manage the writing class with me what
we've done is we've partnered up with a
bunch of people who aren't like-minded
but they do share similar values to us
and they're people that we enjoy knowing
yeah and so yes i'm incredibly grateful
for the team as well amen me too
um you know when someone says thank you
i always respond with well thank you for
the support but i had somebody tell me
they're like dude you need to like just
look at someone and say you're welcome
yes so to this matthew i say you're
welcome yeah and big thanks to the team
amen now to get to the rest of his
question here
the most unexpected benefit
that you've discovered since uh becoming
the minimalists
oh my whole life is unexpected um
all the benefits i have in my life
oh i don't know it's really cool to be
able to like again not just
um have a team to work with but like
like the people on the team so yeah
that's a great unexpected benefit is
just really enjoying
um the co-workers when i first stumbled
into minimalism it was it was kind of
about
letting go
and
getting rid of excess stuff
and it still is to a great extent but
the biggest unexpected benefit that came
from that was actually discovering what
enough is
and realizing the point of minimalism
isn't simply subtracting letting go
shedding the excess decluttering or
organizing or whatever you want to call
it
the point is discovering that enough
point
and enough changes as we change
i was single when i first discovered
minimalism
now i have a wife and a daughter and so
what is enough now is different from
what was enough 12 years ago and what is
enough 12 days from now maybe slightly
different so being willing to adjust but
that enough point
really understanding that and knowing
that even though
advertisements and society and culture
especially pop culture might encourage
me to want more than enough
as soon as i get more than enough it
often leads to misery or discontent or
overwhelm or stress or debt or anxiety
more than enough
is by definition
always too much did you enjoy this
standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
slash the minimalists or click the link
in the description your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free